was hältst du von metall das was das für
eine frage
da geht darauf ein ja metall ist ein
tolles tolles metall ist erstmal
vielseitig nell gibt viele metalle hallo
ich meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft excel auf dem hero
server ich habe mir gerade den schönen
milchshake gemacht in so einem ding und
dickflüssig nichts dagegen wenn ich
jetzt nebenbei ein bisschen milchshakes
schlüpfe ich dachte jetzt das beste
gegen erkältung ist selbstverständlich
mit scheck ich hab mir jetzt einfach mal
gemacht
ich wollte ein bisschen auf fragen
eingehen die in letzter zeit oft in den
kommentaren standen und darauf wenn ich
jetzt eigentlich während ich mir jetzt
erstmal
babbel muss ich mir holen erst mal mein
komplettes inventar ist voll deswegen
denke ich werde noch eine kiste eben
machen wo ich so ein paar sachen einfach
rein läge die ich jetzt erstmal nicht
brauche so warum habe ich hier wieder so
kommt es doch ein rolls brauche ich auch
nicht das aluminium auch erstmal nicht
für den dieb erst recht nicht und jetzt
werde ich erst mal ein bisschen babbel
ab und gehen währenddessen werde ich
dann mal eben auf twitter schreiben
aber was ich denn so reden soll was ihr
so für vorschläge habt so jetzt post ich
nämlich mal eben bei twitter hier so ne
twitter.com / congo after schreibt mir
fragen für schreibt mir themen wie hero
mit dem hashtag conhit so getwittert
jetzt müssen wir eben hier den dänen den
hashtag angucken hashtag von hero summe
angucken oder sind schon ganz viele
andere sachen geschrieben wurden von so
amerikaner motors darf ja da egal warten
ab oder eventuell gleich ein paar fragen
dann kommt währenddessen bei euch ja so
ein bisschen ab und zwar werden
natürlich die häuser wenn der kongress
an der macht ist er macht wir sind ja
alle an der macht ich bin eine soziale
partei dann werden die häuser
selbstverständlich alle gemeinschaftlich
aussehen wie in anderen städten auch in
statt gelb ist es eigentlich gar nicht
so hat jeder irgendwann sei seinen
eigenen style wahrscheinlich die ersten
kommentare ein okapi erst mit youtube
angefangen und so was ja das ist ja
nicht als öl ball drüber geredet
ich hatte ne weile in osterferien mal
irgendwann angefangen mit zum anderen
kanal aber der war cacau herrlich den
gelöscht dann habe ich immer wieder
neuen kanal angefangen da war dann cool
und ja ein bisschen goldner kann man
auch mal mitnehmen
kann er noch mal gebrauchen sagt einmal
so schön so was wollt ihr sonst das
alles geschrieben aktualisieren ja was
hältst du vom fc bayern ja ich bin
bayern fan seit 14 jahren weil ich
damals mit ganz jungen alter mal im
stadion war gegen sporting lissabon war
das 1 0 zu 0 da war ich glaube ich zwar
schon zehn oder so eine spitzhacke gut
oder wie ich glaube vielmehr ist es für
euch davon nicht gut denn sonst noch mal
ganz kurz
ich glaube dann brauche ich noch
feuchten sand wasser jetzt diese kleinen
kapellen ganze server stützt sich
abwägen ganz ränder fehler hier
ich werde meine ganze ganze sand hier
mit ich möchte auch obst die schaufel
ist kaputt die schaufel ist einfach
kaputt gegangen am sonntag bauen
oha wie krass ich glaube ich denn jetzt
36 das reicht locker ihr sie so
dementsprechend sind nun die häfen
wieder auf hochtouren ich will jetzt
einfach mal mit red wings die ich
brauche so viel glas wie nur geht wie
nur geht
da kommt noch du rein und da kommt nur
du rein und du hier als brennmittel und
hier noch und das ist das eigentlich
auch sei das glas haben wir dann auch
fertig werde also bayern ist unbedingt
mein absoluter lieblingsverein
davids ich muss diese milchshake immer
mal zwischendurch schütteln weil der
wirt in die so schnell dickflüssig das
ist richtig auch klug das jetzt einfach
direkt neben die mikrochips schmeckt
besser
stand passend mich jetzt alle besteck
nebenbei trinke jamaika bayern mag ich
aber jetzt nicht weil ich erfolgsfilmen
sondern ich bin sogar fan von denen
gewesen als sie dann in europa league
war niemand kurzzeitig auch mal eine
saison auf platz 14
da war ich immer noch fan und immer im
stadion dabei und in der zweiten liga
bin ich arminia bielefeld fährt weil ich
da wohne aber sonst ja bayern mag ich
eigentlich jetzt hast mich alle für
meine entscheidung sind dorf einfach
geld wartet mal ganz kurz
sie wich das bauer geht mal haus so ein
bisschen
ich kann jetzt einfach mal schon mal an
zu bauen und zwar ein bisschen hier auf
jeden fall da muss man immer so da sind
102 neue fragen hast du eine freundin
zur zeit nicht
ich hatte eine vor paar wochen habe
schluss gemacht weil die hat nicht
akzeptiert dass ich einfach gottgleich
bin ich keine freundin
wie motiviert du dich am besten um für
klausuren und sowas zu lernen ich habe
eine totale motivation schwäche das ist
keine krankheit das habe ich mit
ausgelassener ich hab keine motivation
schwäche ich habe eine ich bin einfach
faul
bei mir ist es so kenne dieses zitat
einen ort productive in die lässt werden
in wie days before oder so
das heißt dass man dass ich am
produktivsten bin werde ich unter stress
arbeitet ich bin so ein stress arbeitet
das heißt wenn ich an einem montag eine
klausur schreiben ich habe das ganze
wochenende welche samstag auf sonntag
noch was mit freunden am sonntagabend
schaue ich mir die ganzen sachen an und
schreibt ihnen wieder trotzdem mit 2 -
das ist so mein durchschnitt eigentlich
so ich kann halt wirklich einfach nicht
seine spitzhacke ich kann halt wirklich
nicht einfach so sagen okay ich schreibe
in einer woche eine klausur ich fange
jetzt mal zu lernen das ist nicht luca
da bin ich nicht das kann ich einfach
nicht ich weiß nicht woran es liegt ich
wünschte mir auch es wäre einfach anders
aber da denkt sich dann auch einfach mal
lehrer
lasst mich bäckt anleihen schnell flug
wurde sein ein bisschen chillen ein
nee also ja ich kann nicht so arbeiten
ich kenne die kälte hätten nee ich kann
ich kann wirklich nicht lernen wenn ich
weiß in zwei wochen schreibt der klausur
da denke ich bin eher so jo ich habe ja
noch zwei wochen zeit nicht in zwei
wochen schreibe also motivieren geht
gegangen ich habe mich auch noch tipps
freiheit so wo willst du studieren wenn
es in hamburg ist wo genau ich werde
wahrscheinlich wirtschaftspsychologie
studieren oder marketing
ich denke eher wirtschaftspsychologie
und das höchstwahrscheinlich in hamburg
wo genau will ich sagen weil das ist
dann doch ein bisschen privat da kommen
die ganze zeit neue fragen was ist dein
lieblingsspiel minecraft willst du den
super bowl 2014 gucken ja ich denke ich
wär doch nebenbei richtig richtig viel
twittern
weil ich richtig bock hat richtig viel
zu twittern das ist der grund also super
bowl ist ja fängt ja um 0 uhr 20 an oder
so da kommt dann kumpel zu mir und dann
wollten wir das selbstverständlich zu
sammeln uns in dem fernseher anschauen
dementsprechend wird es ab halb eins von
mir richtig richtig richtig viele tweets
geben weil ich auch leidenschaftlicher
nfl fänden es spielt ja denn war gegen
zettel überlegen ob ich das überhaupt
alles richtig bau war ich einfach die
ganzen profis bei ich glaube schon
ihr seht schon wie etwa der slacker
stadt wird ich hoffe mal dass dieser
folge fertig wer sonst hätte ich einfach
noch eine da nicht so viele fragen
kommen dass es richtige motivation pur
hier wieder das ist motivation
aber nicht zum lernen so ja ich werde
auf jeden fall den super bowl gucken
meine sinne wieder 100 neue fragen wie
stehst du dazu das ist das ein ms
project gibt was du davon schon das
gehört ich hab so ein bisschen
mitbekommen dass es gibt jetzt immer so
mega projekt abklatschen es gibt auch
mini projekt mittlerweile und so was
alles ich war sollen sie es machen mir
ist es egal
mega projekt war die idee von simon und
mir das hero projekt war die idee von
simon der wollte das ja neu machen
irgendwie für mich ist es so dass ich
finde wenn man so etwas macht dann ist
es natürlich in ordnung ich meine wir
haben es ja auch nicht erfunden dass wir
viele leute auf einen server einfach
drauf packen das gab sein amerika auch
schon vorher nur wir haben ja nicht
einfach in amerika hieß das glaube ich
und wie ist es denn in amerika sagen wir
mal in amerika hieß es jobs gestern
haben wir jetzt natürlich dann nicht
blogs cars genannt oder so näher weil so
ist es ja vom megapark zu mini projekt
mehr oder weniger als es hieß nicht aus
jux kassen youtuber in england aber ich
hab mal gesagt wird das hätten wir es
nicht blogs cars genannt
man sollte ich dann schon was neues
ausdenken die habt einfach genau gleich
gemacht haben sogar vor dem gleichen
zieht so mehr oder weniger deswegen war
es ein bisschen auffällig ja so ich
brauch mal jetzt hier eben das andere
hier dich hier brach ich brauche ich so
was haben wir sonst auch so wie stellst
du dir deine zukunft fort was würdest du
gerne alles erreichen in deinem leben
also zukunftsvorstellung hab ja gerade
schon gesagt hoffentlich studienplatz
wenn ich den nicht bekomme werde ich
denke ich sogar noch köln ziehen für ja
einfach bis ich dann bis ich dann das
wartesemester dadurch habe und dann
einfach damit paar leuten viel weil
viele von meinen freunden nach köln
gehen und vielleicht auch schon den
zahlen kenne aber ich denke man davon
aus dass ich ein studienplatz in hamburg
bekommen werde dann werde ich nach
hamburg ziehen dann dort 34 jahre
studieren bisschen chili studie leben
youtube weiter laufen lassen und dann
halt beruf und dann muss ich gucken wie
lange ich dann noch youtube laufen
lassen wie leicht das hinkriegen wenn
ich dann acht stunden alltag im beruf
ich werde versuchen mich so schnell es
geht irgendwie selbständig zu machen
aber man kann natürlich nicht wenig
in wien studierte vier jahre sein wenn
man ich bin 22 23 kann ich natürlich
denn dann nicht direkt selbständig
machen geht natürlich nicht erfreut
also ja ich denke die zukunft will man
mit sehen was die zukunft bringt meine
lieben freunde lädt über deiner kindheit
was waren denn ihr thema meiner kindheit
was auf jeden fall
es war der irrtum ich dachte wirklich
immer bürger sind gesund das war ein
grosser irrtum meiner kindheit nach der
order salat drauf und alec baldwin und
gönnern und offline studio vor gesund
das dachte ich immer ich dachte autos
werden nur riesengroße marienkäfer ich
weiß nicht warum ich dachte es einmal
wir waren auf wir waren im urlaub und da
dachte ich so als ich dann wieder so
deutsche autos meine mutter was
marienkäfer blablabla und ja aber sonst
kann ich mich daran nicht erinnern das
ist ein bisschen traurig welche anime
ist der lieblings anime und wenn du ein
pokémon wer ist welches wärst du dann
deine lieblings pokémon fleischkonsum
schüttelt dabei mal wieder sein schwanz
ich habe lieblings ich liebe pokémon das
ist mein lieblings anime und mein
lieblings pokémon ist habe ich schon mal
gesagt scheer ochs und
xerox und während andere dieser blaue
kefer ich habe jetzt noch einfällt sagt
steht ja sonst doch sprechen über den
diesjährigen sommer ja was werde ich
machen ich werde wahrscheinlich in der
nordsee fahren weil ich da jedes jahr
hinfahre da wo ich auch schon mal
erkannt fand ich mega weniger süß
einfach die person die mich erkannt hat
das war echt witzig war halt so 14 jahre
alt oder so kam dann bist du komm
crafter und hat mich vorher schon sich
angeguckt und so was alles und ich so ja
werde ich aber das war die zeit wo ich
im sommer im urlaub war und wo ich über
nebenbei dann lief das war so witzig da
hab ich ihn gefragt
weißt du denn war nicht aus wohl
wiederkommen er wusste nicht genau was
ich aus dem urlaub wieder komme weiß
davor einen tag in dem video gesagt habe
was ich vor gedreht habe und sogar im
urlaub noch die videos geschaut dass mir
echt so witzig richtig schön hier unten
kommt übrigens auch diese spur
auch dieses holzes das könnte ich erst
mal machen bevor ich die scheibe
einsätze strand sommersonne freunde was
man halt so macht nächstes projekt your
knees projekt keine ahnung ich wollte
mit gommel eigentlich meinen job machen
aber irgendwie haben sie dazu gekommen
dieser halloween web weiter auch wenn
dich zu hause war als hier aus kam aber
sonst
ich glaube es soll was neues nach tirol
kommen das will ich glaube das wird geil
ich habe da schon so einige sachen
gehört ich bin noch dabei aber
aber ich möchte jetzt nicht verraten
nichts sagen kann spekulieren was hältst
du von stadt pink finde ich kacke ohne
scheiß ich finde sowas doof ich meine
wir haben zugeteilte städte bekommen und
das hat einfach welche da außer außer
master schlagen finde ich nicht so gern
aber es ist halt einfach brocken vom
dreh wieder das immer salva vollidioten
somit wird der sonst so geschrieben
wir sind schon mal 15 minuten wie hast
du den erkennen gelernt ich habe ihnen
damals mal angeschrieben
als ich hatte glaube ich 10.000 moment
und irgendwie 1000 oder sowie und ja
keine ahnung
und dann habe ich einfach mal gefragt so
hey blabla ich finde eine videos ganz
geil und habe ihn dann auch in einem
video von mir erwähnt in dem putsch
video wo ich dann sondern jetzt pusch
gemacht habe hatte ich den er auch dabei
doch dann gesagt den us kanal ist ganz
egal dann ist ja immer mehr abgegangen
mit den august jetzt mittlerweile hat ja
auch mehr als ich glaube ich und
daraufhin haben wir dann halt immer mehr
projekte gemacht werden die today show
laufen dann haben wir uns auch auf der
gamescom getroffen werden uns den er bei
der etwa die erste person von youtube
die mich so gesehen hat so wie ich
wirklich aussehe
das war auch ganz witzig wo er dann so
gesehen hat wie ich aussehen also hey du
siehst ja vor korrekt noch als blabla
weil er dachte mir das ist komisch
aussah und den und ich waren also nicht
wir waren halt echt irgendwie genau
gleich so vom wir haben auch die gleiche
musik geschmack und so was alles und ja
keine ahnung
wir kennen uns schon seit zwei jahren
jetzt glaube ich mittlerweile aber was
heißt kennen wir mal zusammen auf und
bin echt haben uns erst dreimal gesehen
glaube ich hast du zurzeit eine freundin
hab ich auch schon beantwortet werde ich
gefragt ob du nur willst oder wolltest
du das selber rein
es war nicht so dass man sagen konnte
wir schreiben uns hier mal ein sondern
nur simon hat ein paar leute ausgewählt
das waren halt einige aus megaprojekt
einige auch nicht aus dem megaprojekt es
ein paar leute die sich da halt die wo
simon meint soja die hätte ich gerne
niveau dabei weil es ist ja simons
projekt an sich und deren waren da
irgendwie so weil sie nicht so 14 leute
da so die von anfang an so safe dabei
waren darunter wandern ich dabei tadel
zum beispiel so leute die man dabei
haben wollte dehner et cetera komme der
onyx traurigerweise nicht mehr dabei ist
das heißt traurigerweise deswegen konnte
zombie dazu kommen dann wird das alles
immer ausgeglichen
aber sonst hat sie mich gefragt ob ich
da bock drauf habe und dann habe ich
einfach gedacht ja habe ich
so warte ich schon mal wieder ein tolles
foto an wieder die wand vorne aussieht
naja ok da kommt ziemlich diese diese kg
drauf de.com dahin davon nämlich mal
gleich alle mit weil ich davon jetzt an
gemeinsam paar mehr setzen muss und zwei
mal hierhin und auch hier oben hin nein
da nicht jacobo alles fit im schritt bei
dir die stars anders die ski-stars
anderen das von angewöhnt ja hier drüber
kommt wahrscheinlich noch seinen laufweg
so aus blüten damit man dann einfach so
rüber sprinten kann aber sonst in
unserer stadt auf jeden fall geregelt
werden wenn ich könig bin hashtag ctp in
die kommentare schreiben
das jetzt vom fc bayern die hatten wir
schon drei mal die frage 81 neue
ergebnisse kannst du bei deinen traum
leben reden meinen traum leben ist das
was ich gerade führe ich liebe mein
leben zurzeit es ein bisschen doof jetzt
zur zeit mit abi stress blabla obwohl
ich sag mal wie stress blabla obwohl
schon gar nicht wirklich gelernt habe
aber ich muss jetzt langsam anfangen zu
lernen und so was alles dann ist es
nicht so geil aber traum leben wäre
eigentlich studienplatz in hamburg
wohnen hamburg und youtube nebenbei
laufen lassen und viele freunde in
hamburg finden und so komplett was heißt
neues leben aber ich hab so mit den
leuten die bei mir auf die schule gehen
damit den habe ich noch nicht so viel
gemacht halt
weil ich weiss nicht also natürlich man
geht dann zusammen irgendwie sport
machen oder sowas und man lade deine
pause halte aber jetzt seiner freizeit
macht halt mal was mit anderen leuten
die dann halt auf andere schulen gehen
oder aus anderen städten kommen weil
weise licht ist halt einfach so hat sich
so entwickelt und deswegen ich bin da
komplett offen für neue leute die ich
kennenlerne und das ist halt dann so
fände ich ganz cool
was hältst du von metall hin dass das
für eine frage
da geht nicht darauf ein ja metall ist
ein tolles tolles metall ist erstmal
vielseitigen gebe viele metalle gibt es
im periodensystem mit metall oder alkali
metalle gibt es gleich aber egal was das
für ein scheiß frage was hast du am
meisten an der schule
ich finde die schule eigentlich
mittlerweile das feld dann erst immer so
später auf ist die schule echt ganz geil
das muss man einfach so sagen man hat in
der schule so viele möglichkeiten man
kann schön man kann am handy sitzen
man kann auch im unterricht aufpassen
alles mögliche kann man wirklich in der
schule eigentlich machen
diese habe ich eigentlich nur so wenig
kommission wollte ich habe einen stack
das steht da ja schön und die schule ist
halt echt mega entspannt im vergleich zu
einem beruf natürlich beruf acht stunden
du kriegst keine prüfungen oder
irgendwie sowas aber beim beruf ist es
halt wirklich so du musst dann halt auch
die acht stunden umsetzen und halt
wirklich arbeiten in der schule sogar
fast pausenlos unterschiedliche fächer
und alles man sollte recht stolz sein
und so froh sein so lange wie möglich in
der schule zu bleiben und was ich auch
eigentlich machen wollte ich wollte
eigentlich komplette oberstufe noch mal
wiederholen damit ich länger an der
schule bleiben dabei dass leben in der
schule ist will ich einfach und ich weiß
studien leben ist noch billiger aber
naja
so ich brauche gleich unbedingt diese
teil um die kisten oben zu werfen ja ja
ich denke ich werde auch sogar noch eine
folge machen
so jetzt noch die letzte frage schreiben
die ich viele mädchen an
zurzeit immer mehr also bei instagram
habe ich mittlerweile mehr weibliche
follower als männliche
da habe ich ja auch schon mal ein video
auf instagram gemacht instagram dot com
/ laser luca es im folgen immer noch
leute instagram dort kommt braucht es
ein fake das ist den können melden
blockieren den arsch fristen keine
ahnung ich hasse faker völker sind so
apathie warum macht man so war es so
dass kunden da oben drauf bauen wird von
der seite ach da kommt auch die teile
hin hier kommen die auch in menschen die
haben ja überall hin gebaut
zurzeit schreibe ich immer mehr mädels
an und bei instagram hat mich jetzt auch
irgend so eine von gm
ich habe ein bild gepostet als ich in
hall ist irgendwie drin war dass die
meta sein angebot gemacht haben ob ich
da arbeiten möchte und ich habe
selbstverständlich direkt gesagt nur
kein bock auf euch ich hab bei instagram
ebt auf sondern sind pml model irgendwie
angeschrieben die wohl auch die sieht
auch mega geil aus irgendwie aber ich
habe keine ahnung warum die mich als
irgendwie anschreiben ob das ist wegen
youtube oder wegen sonst was ich
antwortete ja nie kein bug draft ich
habe auch keinen bock in dem model zu
werden oder irgendwie sehe mich ja auch
ich finde mich total potthässlich
irgendwann mal ein gebüsch arrogant
anschreiben ja schönste so was spielst
du was wann spielst du das game was du
gesagt hast einmal gesagt ach ja ich hab
mal gesagt dass ich nur game spiele
das war das was
wie hieß das keine ahnung wie das hieß
aber das war ist auf jeden fall mega
krass das hat mich ein kumpel gefragt
das wollen wir mit der koloss rift
spielen
aber irgendwie habe ich geld für
lockeres rift wird der mega schnell
schlecht und da wir auch in kassel
karussells und so auch mal schlecht wird
wäre das wohl voll die scheißidee wenn
ich das spielen würde deswegen habe ich
gesagt mehr kommen lassen wir mal lieber
habe ich jetzt überall diese teile ich
eigentlich drauf da hinten fehlt noch
ich bin schon vorüber ziehen
verdammt ihr seht auf jeden fall schon
so langsam wie sich das hier entwickelt
wird mit den häusern
so soll es dann in etwas später überlauf
sehen also die häuser sehen werde
natürlich noch ein bisschen anders wir
noch ein bisschen schöner aber so soll
es überall ausgehen dass das so eine
schöne stadt wird ein bisschen wie
venedig ein bisschen mit die in hamburg
mit den flüssen so zwischen her
natürlich sagen es euch gefallen hatte
ich mal vom server unter last eine
positive bewertung da sagt kain von den
anderen teilnehmer dass ich bisschen
überzogen habe und es sind jetzt schon
wieder 70 neue fragen bei twitter
deswegen darauf werde in der nächsten
folge gegen die sich bei mir zu hause
oder rein schreibt hierzu zählen die
kommentare was gut und teuer